no no no no
good
yes
[Music]
friends we are back here in
san luís fast and clicks in the
luxury tournament we have grandmaster gary
kasparov very happy very
excited the first round is over let's go to the
second round
a live broadcast from the city of san louis
missouri here with the grandmaster
alejandro ramírez and his friend ivette
garcía definitely strong emotions
we were already in the first round
maybe sentry boxes but it was not the
show that everyone expected but
the others were good  what a way to play lion
now with an absolutely
brilliant game against dávila bala who arrived
at the studio completely shocked and so
in total good but also hikaru
nakamura wins the game against vision and
starts with a win with the
black pieces but final
in history  of the day as fabiano caruana has let go of
an entire point
losing in the last seconds of the
entire and blunder he had a queen as well as a
queen  he also had against le quang liem and
the american player ends up losing
well they applied a very
difficult game to you a very dry game if it gets
too complicated and what do you think if
we go to the second round nakamura kaspar
we got a camera that was and
outside where we are broadcasting
and preparing preparing as you see
if obviously it is going to be the duel of the day it is
going to be the duel of the day since well
nakamura who starts by beating the
former world champion vision he
continues now against the legend the legend
yes but he also grabs because he goes with the
black pieces and nakamura we know he
has excellent preparation he is a
player who stays on top of
theory he can play anything he is
hard to predict extremely aggressive
in quick time controls it is going to be
a tough duel here for gary kasparov
hopefully and hopefully  if we really
also have the stick with fabiano caruana
who predicted you have for that game
the players who hit  the
first round was hard
and I think he will know what to see how
tough the players are because
the first round
was really hard for them, yes it was very, very hard for both of them I say
some draws aronián epo
aronián I think aaron is playing
incredible I really think he is
incredible aronian because white also
yes I think we have a
heretic result lenier dominguez love leger dominguez
i think he is a
solid player who will win he just lost a
go with black but on sunday dominguez will
try to win
definitely the best
player here  latin american
rapid game specialist is going to try the ncaa
and complete at home of course if we
don't have to go to aller domínguez
latin american currently the best
latin american player
with 2700
39 of him or against the former
world champion go and I'm going to come karjakin
licua mbia
face here against le quang liem it
seems to me that the one who had some
luck we have already seen what happens when
he has a little bit of luck he needed
nothing else he needed a little bit of luck
and he wins the tournament the cup without end
and well what do you think and a few days here I think
it suits
even some black pieces to try
to put pressure
imagine that a lequan well well  well
nobody gives him two cents that the
tournament arrives here he starts to win
there there are bets here well
we already have the handshake here
and we will do it later because we already have
hikaru nakamura's game against
gary kasparov and of course the one that dies
against garry  kasparov
let's go to the camera to see them directly
in which we have a cross see with the
agro and technical specialist cas for his
specialist in the grünfeld and well we
have here at last for 60 per efe
six per se a line a little older
animal  but perfectly playable
let's continue on camera let's continue on camera let's
continue on camera here in the players
because well what a pleasure to see you today we go
on camera
we have a typical position  but it is a
typical position here
where they spent a player well known
for this type of schemes like grünfeld
makes a c6 quickly to question
the structure of white's not
as we have already seen in this in
these games in recent games where
we come to  a very similar structure
like four out of four and out of five
well well
we have nakamura against kasparov here
without a doubt I am going to
kasparov to gary kasparov from
boyacá tell us who you are
nakamura kasparov sending your messages
thanks for following this  transmission
sending your comments your messages
your questions here we are going to be very
attentive to your comments yes and for the
moment
we have an opening that caspar already knows
that is how well prepared he has
come to the tournament he plays quickly
against nakamura after pawn by 5
we have knight by 5 for example
as an idea but of course the
counter idea is so that when he removes the
bishop the p  eon of 4 we had already
seen in the cup
rather it will end up with black where the
pawn of 4 that adif difficult very weak
in that in this game what carvana
fabric did was to give itself the pawn structure
of 5 which is also perfectly considered
playable for black what
he has that possibility and carlos
maybe there were 5 closing the center
we are going to see which of the variants that
are all possible can be played if
we saw this position in the
singles tournament with fabiano caruana where what result
did we have in
and in that game
and I think they draw but there is a
little more left of the opening so good that
the pair of bishops nakamura had for me
for me this position
is very very important the decision that is
going to be made because well so many pawns for
iu no  they move away or I don't know what this thinks
here it seems to me that it is a position that
although it is playable for both
sides it is slightly more comfortable for
white strategically the problem of the
round of four to  now it is more yes
but the space of the idea of a h4 h5 very
uickly causes problems on the k
ngside it is a duel and a little more
irec
where let's say gary is going to have that
tructural advantage this stati
advantage as we say but in a way
dynamics there is a form of development what
clearly has the advantage is
hikaru nakamura so we have that
typical duel in the position
if I really like white's position
here it seems to me that he is very
flexible despite the fact that many times
we see that h  485 can be played
we have the problem of black that I
cannot attack the pawn of 4 as
easily as he would like one wants
nothing else here to put the knight that 6 of
thank you very much for following this
transmission how kind of you to follow us
giving us your comments please  and
well here they are sending us many
greetings from
brazil and venezuela and thanks for all
your comments and well we had a
little problem there with the synchronization
of the audio but for  I pray that they are already
fixing it
and well if we have a couple of
technical problems but we are fixing it at
this moment he is not
asking me what has
been left of my great teacher
well at 15 I did bleeding in 2003
well
and if he hit me  something let's go to the camera to
see here the great players here he is not
thinking about what plan he wants to have
i love seeing kasparov how he thinks
how he thinks i like the energy he
gives off when he is in a position
and i love
this expression it's how he looks  I tell him, look
and expensive, you have to give him a little look, not
two decades, where does
his killer look, if he looks like a killer, is it
known as amazing?
outside here
we are here in the club part we are
in a restaurant that is also part
of the club is part of the campus is already
well dressed his coach with his
laptop there in a little corner to  that no
one sees it and that is where they go, he assures them
between the rounds so that I tell him that
what I am going to play here is that I
was preparing it
when precisely
and well we have nakamura let's remember
that the time we have is 25 minutes
with 10 seconds  of delay 25 minutes with
10 seconds of delay remember that the
delay is different from the cumulative one it is not the
same if here you will never ever go away
so you cannot accumulate time it is
basically what it means I
send greetings from Spain following you
while I have dinner  the best
company with you impossible thank you very
much thank you very much for your
comments greetings to spain greetings to
brazil very poor cat thanks for seeing us
and well then what do you think if
we move on to another game well
aronian's game and why can't we miss
that one  game where aronian started
winning started winning a game of
hers a beauty award totally
where we had david navara here in the
studio yes that really  Entity was shocked
yes
well let's go then to that game we
're going to aronian's game with the
community
let's go with whoever it was that this
game was
this typical idea that we saw an h 4 an h 5
a tower h 4 in the infocap an idea  very
interesting for him
tf1
344 plays here aronian at day 7 h5 let
's go forward that you go to the file
twice and king f1 improves it the subtle that a
milestone here efe 1 leaving has
not yet analyzed the idea of kings some
hat we have said that  no although
short it was not possible even in rock el agro
but that the king had a very
safe position in f1
yes definitely because let's remember that
there were problems with the g2 pawn in this
variation and the king of f1 directly to
fix these problems the king too
it feels a little more comfortable because
many tables when they can four if
I am going to be able to play five since the bishop
is not in check by 0-3
the position and the ideas
I have to play
very creative very creative and 4
castling short bishop to  3 bishop of f5 and
king now a little safer on axis 1
as an artificial castling but the
rook continues with the pressure here on the
h-file rook ef of 8 called 4 that
is the position after we be a
creative that is aaron that  creative that
develops in a tower f1 tower 8 years ago
and for the moment has managed to
nepomniachtchi and
fully develop but in return
aaron and have managed to establish a great
center and the wave of potential problem
on the h column is still not so
easy for the economy anymore  like
focusing completely on the center
you can't play let's say a 5 without taking into
account that if there are certain
changes
the queen can transfer to the field to
the kingside and threaten things like that
if I really like aronian's precision
very creative  it is very creative
i like it quite a lot yes now well 19
minutes new 24 how many 24 minutes and 4
minutes
aronian that he has consumed has taken a
lot of time to eat
extremely fast player sum  I'll give you
a classic tournament when, well, if it
was ipsa, in fact, he said it, yes, he said it here,
we had the team in the studio and he said,
well, I had to think about
what was happening because they began to be
infected by losing the first two
rounds, and well  We see that he did
have these problems
and here he
continues to play very fast, it is not enough
for him to win the jr game
but he did have a
fairly solid game over there ok
let's continue then let's go back to the
kasparov game that we always
have to see let's go
we are being greeted by garry kasparov from france luisa
colombia-france thank you for following this
transmission let's go to another game what do you
think if we take a look
at who is not the best of the tournament
nakamura hikaru nakamura who starts by
beating to watch against garry
kasparov  to firm 5 to 15 4 and this
interesting moment where he will decide how to
go instead of protecting the knight that
is not so easy I don't know why if give me
3 bishop  because of efe 3 I can't take a queen
because the knight for the boss
wouldn't have to take rest, it's already
horrible instead a knight that one
simply takes off to remove the
fence from the bishop and eventually
the knight will return the bishop doesn't
have very good
knights either  it's not a nice move a
nice move yes
at a certain moment
efe 445 if it can be it depends on how he
plays escaped from regrouping the
knight to a place perhaps more useful for
the moment if we see here in the
players on camera and with caspar o
thinking after h3 because the idea of
g1 is that the dg4 bishop only
ants to make a life is to exchange it it doesn
t have any good diagonal and then
t's over he doesn't let it can finis
the turn so that in the end it can't be ex
hanged for him  knight maybe gets
rid of the dolphin and only
when he got to the film he is not in four he
returns either f 3 2
I see a good square for the bishop
since when
5 but it is always latent there was
some shots I don't know I don't really
like where I could after h3 we could
make sf-bishop five ideas as
5-bishops take between 6 or leave
the plates dormant there and for sf 6 bishop for sf 6
then play
the idea that I had told you gentlemen
I rode efe 4
I don't know I like it gentlemen
if I pack I'm also going to play files 6 and
since I was at this moment that sometimes
even the most notorious one doesn't because when
the horse 4 won it with a tempo if
aside I really like the position
after  of him because of ef 6 because they
are forcing me to make an angel because of ef
6 because after sport en face it is because of
ef 6 I don't really like the position to
stop them
for black if here I have the
decision fixed that if he wants to change
nf6 or play a  a little bit more
crazy maybe like f4 than if he keeps the
center but of course he risks his
position because the more the pawns advance the
weaker his
structure is 2006 I like to take
I really like to take s  in nf6 I really like
this position after rook because of
efe 6 because I'm forced I can't
do it because it's falling
on 6 I can make a knight the same
idea or maybe it fits I like it on f3
to put it in n 5
but there are blows here in this position it is
good that f6 was taken which seemed to me
the most logical move
here and gavin if he has a choice he
can also take as a pawn to eventually
play f5 or he can take as a bishop to
directly attack the 4-pawn of
course  that basically would force a
knight that there are 2
what he wins I change a capture expression
on 5 expression on certain
positions I would say a bit risky
for kaspar that is to say he managed to keep the
pressure on 51.1 a knight
is indeed an f 4 strategically it gets
complicated  his position
yes because good house forced by efe
six rooks between six here I like
two before I can't play horse
efe three basically suicidal because of the
simple tutors by efe 3 1
intuitive of course because of 4 and it is very
dangerous if there is a subtle pair
both the bishop of
g7 and the bishop of 6 begin to free themselves a king in the
center go if they say that talking
about shirt is very fashionable aronian today
very easy very  easy well
we can also see the games here
of kasparov incredible that they return to
the boards and how the day starts it
is the last tournament who knows with a
player as well as cash but he has
so much energy he says no he says
no  come back no no he says that this is his
last tournament but who knows not
always what you wanted
when I went it was yes but that was more than
an exhibition
well we didn't have here who really taught
these great players that we had in
fact we have the government in charge
of  nakamura where simply friends a
shell that had problems with
time in that tournament we hope that this is
not the occasion because it reaches
very won games and suddenly
the position fell  ion due to the
lack of time like you what was your
perception in that tournament it seemed to me that he
arrived a little enlightened that despite the fact
that it was really just more of an
exhibition that he arrived with encouragement but
that it was seen that he had not played for a long time
I don't have many
games where I was totally won
and it went away and it went away
if I totally missed the time and well if
you have to see them
if Torres plays here because of EFE six they
stayed that we were waiting
quickly all Mexican in that 6 and
here  as we said the knight
cannot go to f3 because there is a risk that
there is that knight sacrifice f3
we have you send knight
gp2 knight gea of 2 and well here the typic
l the typical duel the p
ir of bishops with the worst structure again
t knights but the  stru
note that in what he is going to draw this
afternoon completely tie houses for
the black squares if this horse
manages to reach that 5 and this horse
manages to reach 5 and the kind with a
tower back totally lost
[Music]
in roque try a horse according to a
horse
yes horses in a horse of three that
binds as much as 5.5 could
definitely be here as an idea
horse to 4 and also realistic horse to
4 I like it a lot to send it  5 ago the
rook will probably reach that 1
white would like to put is in one
but thanks to the last move of the rook
to efe eight it is almost impossible no because
I will always have the aggression
caparrós has to maintain the
direct counterplay if he has to  keeping threats
has to keep black
completely open because if
white manages to tie up the bishops and
close the position the bishops will lose
any kind of value at the moment
the biggest problem with kasparov
is choosing on the 6 which doesn't have a good
maneuver  does not have a favorable way to
return to the game rook to 1 we have here
then this duel where it is simply
a matter of taste if one wants to
play with  white or put them I think it
is a dynamically balanced
position yes a very very balanced position what do
you think if we go to see them on camera
if carlos the players on camera one
against kasparov
if shell comes with everything with everyone
the tournament really started very well
some  boards with shells very solid
against kayaking I feel like it was very very
solid in the beginning and well
good sacrifice of kasparov
creatively
when you see this type of position
you start to see the services because it
is the kind of position where
aesthetically black is worse so
it has to change the dynamics of the game
in some way either a break is
made 5 or 5 or remove the bishop either
remove the bishop and juárez 5 or start to
see if bishop x h3 works I don't know if it
works I
don't think so I don't think so  he still has the material
to do it and that is why he is playing 15 8 for
players 5 but there is the idea the
always latent idea of certifying something on the k
ngs
de his sacrifice  cio if she is hard
the sacrifices are hard here you have to be
careful hikaru with
[Music]
and just like everything
and if the 12 sep knight is vital vital
in the knight position gaspar
will get several and from this position
even think of g5 g4  send the
pawn forward and open the kingside
thank you very much to all of you for
following the transmission thank you for being
with us here you are sending us
greetings one says that kasparov is going to act
on the shell arm
what you think I think they are showing
level and this what is the typical dandruff
of which one sees the position of those who go with
energy that is how they like to play
him with energy it makes the game spicy
where he does not like those static games so much
or anything at stake nothing with
get the aggressor and right now
with the pair of bishops with the position
he has here he is putting a
lot of pressure on his opponent they say here
why the gems lose so much time
to play the opening
not so  n critics we talked about it
in the previous transmission about the
good book of critical moments that you turn
green and we move to another position we have to
take a look at it, of
course, the position has already changed
quite a bit and it seems to me that it
is doing well and deformed here
whatever has happened
I think it really benefits them
because what worries me the most about the
position we have here, not
after the current show, is the
one-on-one feeling if I don't like it,
for the rest it has achieved  establish a
control of the center if I get to play 4
change would change the valuation that
I have because if I get to play 4 the queen
could be transferred to efe 4 and h4
start attacking the plan that everything is coming
everything is coming to attack so I would
put it  It is extremely important for me that the
4 does
not happen, because if we do not have
four here for the moment, the queen would be
closed, the bishop would be closed, and that is what
he has to think about, there is no 5 left, he also
keeps 4 as  a more difficult idea to
carry out because it is 4 white would always
be attacked
if the most important thing seems to me to be the
time difference between these players
exactly in economy that is a
specialist in putting pressure on the
clock extremely on the skin extremely
fast 22 minutes of  nepomniatchi against aaron's
9 is good we leave here
thinking aronian let's go to another game
let's go to the game about what he
would do here against him how well we have
to watch all the games we don't have
tremendous games today sergei that we had
to find him when there was still
material  equalized let's
quickly review what happened here
ok
an Italian
typically yes a little more aggressively
recovers the pawn at the end in lequan and there is
the current position I really like the
position
if I also a weak pawn than if I
change the pawn  of flowers of w
also weak action of four and of
course the knight of f5 is touching
here in axis 7 it is touching in 86 and
practically  I actually like Sergey Karjakin's game a little more
, although due
to the good activity of the
black pieces, United States, for example,
Knight makes 4 and I can barely change
the queens. It would be a great achievement for
Warner. It seems to me that the position might
be  more or less equal but I like it
more I like the charity position more
who I think the knight on f5
will always hinder his opponent a lot
if I like the position a lot
by the Russian change kings I
really like this position
what do you think if we go to see them on
camera on camera all the players
let's see if we have the following and
how does a player who does not have as much
experience in the elite as the others
but who have given several tournaments and
have won them  he is the only player who has
won the aeroflot twice
the most important and strongest open
in the world and the only player
who has won it twice elect who has
played dortmund has played several
important tournaments asia championships with
cleanups
but he has not had the opportunity to
face these elite ones a
play with chaos goes away with aronian and
for the moment they
cause aaron and the void
because they are only superior to econ but not
so much that he does not say the  they will always destroy
no no no here who are the banks
juan cardona asking if they are the
economy david navara the cuban lenier dominguez
and of course garry kasparov
those are our white hart yes that in
spanish means
we have a translation for walqa in
spanish it
's like
like  I say as a joker as to
circulate
how good maybe we can analyze this
position a little
greetings from Mexico they say greetings well
thank you
here ask send us the comments
greetings
we have just been very very
attentive send us also who you think will
win the tournament who will look for the  tournament
yesterday I was also practicing as
gray and I told him and I always feel
sure that with an 11  % that cas because
among the first the first three
had already said nakamura first
and third
let's see if that works for you I think
it is but not among the first three it's
really easy to underestimate the calera
if that's what we bet with
precisely card  invitation
of invitations
so that they are teaching us
Spanish here it is about chess and
from grancanaria they are greeting us
thank you very much
isaac gonzález thank you for following this
transmission
here they are asking us please to
go to kasparov nakamura kasparov's game of
course they are
asking us  that if we can go to the game
of dandruff 2 if we go to the game to the
camera of kasparov
nakamura kasparov
yes, without a doubt, it must be, it must be,
we have to see the grimaces, of course, it opens the
cas position for, as we can already see
with a 5
where it allows  bring his bishops to life
what does he want to
make his bishops come to life nakamura
at the moment with sb4 see what sb4  he's
stopping black's hanging pawn structure he's
trying to install
that s5-knight we talked
about some time ago and he's holding the position
which is in his favor he has an obligation to
find some way to open the
position even a bit more I like it he already
has  I like to give the black position a
lot a lot really it seems to me that it
has a certain advantage a certain
advantage the other debate is that the
bishops are extremely powerful in the
position the knight is 5 if it is going to
bother a lot it has to play with a
certain  precision has to play with
some precision
nakamura
the bishop of that 8 is very dangerous
because it is late at night 3 always
elements I am going to see a goal over there
from a murder I can see for her she
always has to be looking for this
type of blows because  with him a
structure that is still inferior to that
of his opponent as we see in we do it he
has two islands of worse against three
ideas of playing a g5 g4 or of playing  bishop
to h3 all these kinds of ideas can be
experienced or seen
for the gardin player because again
if nakamura manages to establish control
over the position outside of
five-knight and defines himself on the
kingside in play a four-knight starts  to
take advantage of an inferior structure of
gaspar or secas to know that at this
moment it is a critical decision of how
the attack is going to continue if the attack
dies it is clear if the attack dies and
the clear target is better because of the
static advantage already  we had talked
about a static advantage over a
dynamic advantage in this game we have
a static advantage on the part of the camera
where he has a position in a
more salvageable pawn structure more
albarrán and healthier and well he has
to somehow justify kasparov
than  webb 14 minutes the camera with
eight minutes of caspar or if he's not well
well he says what he's thinking
immediately when he doesn't see that a
horse is in four  ro
try to think of something like bishop by h
3 let's say bishop by h3 and h3t efe 3 take
on h 3 or something like
that at the moment I'm not so
sure if for let's say we have to take
good care of a knight that three or  something for
him for him it's like that where well
for the moment the kaká turret to the
knight covers many squares
we had already talked about how important
this knight is covering the flank of the king
it seems to me that the sacrifices do not
work and since the sacrifices it
seems to me not  they work and now he is
looking for a way to increase the
pressure you know I liked the
idea a lot I left five g5 they look like ag5 to me because
they give rise to the rook from g6 or h6
we can make five 64 rooks if if he
says g5 it is very  natural in kaspar or yes
yes yes that 5 that is very natural for
kaspar it seems to me that 5
maybe removing that first one from the
column because of course the queen
is quite badly placed
queen of 6 I think it gives more than 6 is a
good way of  begin  the queen
feels much safer and could already
start playing a g5 she plays rather in a
rook 6 I did not expect this move
since because the knight could enter 5 by
hitting the rook with tempo so
let's think for the moment he is
taking advantage of what  the knight doesn't have
very good moves let's say I don't want to
play here from g3 the knight doesn't belong
on g3 in many variants and jobs I
would hope that nakamura quickly became
a 5 knight because it's a really
bad time because if a knight makes 5 what do
I have to do  rook 8 doesn't seem to me I can't
make rook you say because well it
wouldn't make sense 9 3
no rook 7 or rooks is what I would
probably play rook on seven
bolts problemly on 8
but if the move surprised me a bit if I pushed
the move a little bit  he gives him
time as we said if white
settles down
i'm not understanding very well i think
what kasparov was afraid of was
that they played him a tournament of one and a
knight of four against  looking at
all the squares here on the flank in
the center but towers 6 no it is not very
attractive to me that sometimes 5 what I am
waiting for in the camera but the
North American is also trying to
understand the idea that because they have
done me and in a  once there as I said
that I go s5 to the rook he immediately throws it 8
and now let's see how nakamura continues
nakamura try to consolidate his
position if it can be a knight b3 which
is very hard I like the knight on b3
because it controls 4  you control and 5 I
like it a
lot you
if I like it after head 5
knight b3 then make a
is that I don't know
try to try here
that we could try here after
this each time production with rook 8 I
like knight b3  knight I like this
idea knight 3 with the idea of putting the other
knight on 4 and try to start
simplifying the position if he can try t
fall from four rooks according to one he would
start in the middle I am
oing to press the structure yes and that
s  Precisely what we are talking
about is what the camera is going to be, not about playing
against the structure, well, we tried to
go to another game that we had already
seen the nepomniatchi game, we saw the
carjacking game, we did not see the linier game,
well, we can not stop it  non-
linear side domínguez against vice two
incredible players win
we go there
than with another berlin but now domínguez
with the white pieces
we play a much more aggressive idea
than normal where white castles
long and starts throwing all the
pawns on the flank of
definitely king and apart black
also has houses with two which is
a typical idea here of white letting
the pawn go because let's say if I
defend it with 354 I have like an anchor
where I can start attacking if I play b3 it
's basically suicidal  against 4 that opens
the rook and that the pair has
both c5 and 6 no no
I don't see it very clearly
definitely now on horseback f5
bishop for 25 bishops of his  tory leave
a rh 8
well everything is being sent here for him
in jr on top of his opponent trying to
play the pawn up trying to
attack the opponent has already sacrificed
a pawn if in exchange for
good he puts a lot of initiative the time
really because he does  hit
this position a lot with h 4 h 5 if on a
knight jan efe five very strong the
rook in which one and the rook in the day before yesterday
one if he has a lot of compensation the clock sees you
no childhood he has five minutes
against ghana with 11 minutes if he has left
very little time at the moment he has to
take care of some dominguez at a certain
moment that if I take an f5 he takes an f5
I have a knight that 4 that would give me I
think an advantage black I think he has to
take jan efe six at a certain moment
to force  black to retake and that
's why they've done rh8 all of them
already foreseeing that his rook is
going to play g8
yes well lenier dominguez was
world champion he was world champion of the
saying in 2012 leave  I'll tell you
what year it was because I'm not very sure and
I don't want to be
lying to you here he
was champion
[Music] he
also won the lips in 2008 I think it
was in 2008 and in 2013 he won the fee
for the great present hall and  quinho
in thessaloniki if we go to the game
because here well rather Sunday
has very little time left he has to play he
has to play Sunday he has 4
and a half minutes left basically he needs to
hurry up and be tender or in a very
interesting position where well he has a pawn
less but he has the attack but that
will not matter at all if he does not manage to
play he has to play something 4 minutes
let's see
he allows us to be thinking and this is that
he is not going to play
because he is seeing it with a cove of 10 4
more skillful minutes  it's something
I love how he thinks back but I
like it a lot as a pizza hunter who
makes many faces and is well
known for his faces if on youtube
when he gives himself a tea leaf Álvaro with
his definitive wheels there is no inc  I rement
the delay, there is no increase, it is legal,
we have a time of 25 minutes with a 10-
second delay, excuse me for
repeating it so much, but many of
us do not know what is
legal because it is a rhythm that is not played
very much,
it is not  common neither in Europe nor in
Latin America
I think that only in the US and even in the US
was he losing ground but rather it
was the influence of dandruff where we
returned to using delay he thought it was
a better system than the
cumulative one where the time changes a lot
in a few moves  that you can make
five or six quick moves and this
totally changes the system would go from
a couple of minutes to ten minutes many
times doing and it is difficult for the
audience to understand that because if
then he decided that
the delay was what would be used in  the great
chef tour as a small experiment
as a small experiment well
well sorry for
repeating it and repeating why but
it is difficult to understand why it is a
time that is not used much so much america
but when what you are going to
see is that 10 seconds are returned to you
the difference between the increment and the
delay is not that the 10 seconds are not going to be
returned to you is that if you do
a play before those that the 10
seconds pass you do not return 10 but
only what you have spent for example if
you play immediately after they
play you do not add 10 seconds
thank you very much to all of you thank you
for following this transmission
thank you very much  We are here waiting for
the chat. Send your questions. We are going
to have luxury guests here. We can see
that David does not speak Spanish.
Yesterday, that is, rumors had reached me
that he spoke Spanish,
but it was not until yesterday that I actually met him
at the ceremony.  opening
and he spoke to me in Spanish and I was
shocked that he speaks eight languages
for six languages and he has play
d 4 times on Sunday is that what he was waiting
for was 45 and efe horse
4 seems like a good idea to me paraná maybe
they were horse efe 4 first in the
pressure on the board it definitely
exists for domínguez but the one about the
anal clock is very well planned very
badly planned
yes exactly the fast and clicky san
luís is the fourth tournament  of the
five we only have one tournament left, the one in
london fast very fast really
fast first was the stoppage and great
tours that the winner was wrong to look for
that was fast clicks the second was an
xbox that was live in belgium where
magnus was also the winner  carlsen and
the third was the sien fico that
ended this great event two days ago where the
winner was maxim bakíyev maxim bayern and
well the last one of this tournament also
how fast we will see who will win
yes and finally close the great chef tour
with  the one in london yes with the one that
will be in november the last of november the
beginning of december how about
we move it to the barricade game against
hikaru nakamura  let's go to camera we have
a couple of decisions at hand the knight is 5
rook 8 and plays ask this knight
b3 with the threat let's say to put a
knight in 4 and start attacking here
the structure and an idea maybe a little
surprising queen bird 2 changed plus the
communes says well okay the problem
keys change and now the problem for
the camera to see where the
knight of two is going to be able for the moment
there is the strong threat of a bishop to
six yes where the pressure on the
knight of two would be extremely uncomfortable
especially with the pin and that is why
I am imagining that what is going to
play a capture of the knight
of four and I liked it a lot it gives us more
means than we have been left notice that at the
beginning when you see queen b2 you say but
well  I have an advantage I have a disadvantage there
is not even its traction is why change it
because change the weapons I don't know if it's the
least you want is to change parts yes
but well this worked it seems that
it looks spectacularly well so  n the
casual bishops are no longer the bishops
that are giving him the compensation here
the pigeons in exchange for his structure
but with all this said I think that without
the queens nakamura has to worry
a little less I don't really have to
worry about what five  much less
of the sacrifice as a bishop for h3 it
seems to me that the american player has recovered some ground
here and after the
bishop of 7 that gary kasparov just played he
can try to start to
consolidate something like rook 2 get rid of the
bishop play about three
eventually try to defend the 4-
knight and 4-knight 5's
obviously I can't stop every time 5's
because the 4's fillmore threatens bishop
by eff 2's so I don't have time to
take on 7's
nakamura with a control with a slight
edge in the  time is not so light
four minutes ahead they have
seven minutes and twenty in the catch
against three and twenty
married 3 minutes and expensive nakamura 7 minutes
pu  is we have to see how this
game ends what to have yes yes we go quickly to
the game of master caruana
if we stop this game here
temporarily here we go for a second
because it has many plays very
quickly horse porsche 6 they have played
very quickly change the structure
completely
and let's go  let's see what is happening the
knight here attacks 7 and attacks at the end
of 24 but he really doesn't want to give the
pair of bishops and has some way
of keeping it define it would but
I don't see how the 36 bishop of 6 and more  ok
he's going to take a risk he's going to let it fall
but I can't not if I can take a 7
it looks risky it looks risky but
why not why not
gaspar or go for the pair of bishops
sacrificing a pawn in an endgame an
excellent concept  I don't know if it works, I eat
it because if not, I don't have
compensation for the pair of files, which
is very strong.
á much better than
nakamura
still still weighs quickly let's see
other games before returning to this
emotion at the end
so the knight many times
about the closed ones and we go to the game of
navarra navarra against caruana we haven't
seen it at all quickly let's see
no  i like what happened to
navarra this f4 knight is going
down but the only reason why
navarra hasn't given up because
everything else seems pretty pretty
bad
if let's say here we go it was a
very typical accepted queen's gambit  of the great
master fabiano caruana
and we see that if we see that he uses the stick a
system very similar to the one that juani used
against him
and we see here that here the position of
white seems very bad to me the knight on
f4 is targeted 2 years ago
yes  because I don't want to open the
king's bank either but what I'm going to do is
I have to keep the pawn of four
live knight by h 7 rook by 4
rooks by 4 rooks by 4 and by faith
if here c  With this control that he has
, Navarre's position looks extremely difficult.
I have already taken axis 2. I have an extra pawn.
If the knight is very nice,
the knight looks very nice, but it is
completely locked up. Yes, that is all.
nothing
knight of 4 takes 4 queen f4 bishop 66
and this position must be totally
lost for the rod is a pawn
down a very weak king rook entry
of two complete control over the knight
df
6 rook
4 of 24 goes  to be a great threat in
general white is almost lost 5
soon they will fall to 5 and well in an
ending we are better much much better yes
yes
we are going then to aronian's game
against nepomniatchi aronian there is only
one minute left to one minute left
last pass  these rounds of three queens
of a queen efe five take take and play
we saw this position where eventually
if aronian manages to play 4 but it costs him
his 2 pawn
and now we have here the material against
the attack  e
passes the queen who economy recovers
then a pawn aronian but again
the ranks very bad I don't see a
direct mate but aronian keeps trying his
attack an fcc knight is a f4 bull the
knight of 5 at the moment what is
saving black  but more than saving
it can give him a certain advantage if he
managed to pass the silken pawn
on a knight of 5 monsters or really
monstrous that threw an octopus
that is leaving aronian stunned he
really
can't play second rook tournaments on
h4 and uncoordinated I would like to play  in
governed by the insurance
totally 1 d4 d5 the queen jan efe three
and they fit five a great great job
keeping the attack out
real danger queen of the bull f8
let us remember that there is only one minute left
and it is not a minute
aronian with epo six minutes 49  seconds
and 6 minutes 49 seconds and I think
also
what do you think if
we leave quickly
the great master fabiano is going to win very expensive coal
let's go very quickly good
well but we can stop this now
caspar we are not going to hunt what his
pair of bishops has
we are going to see how good we have it with a
pawn down but he has just played h4
try to
try to keep a network of mates on
his opponent and see  that nakamura not only
has an extra pawn but he has
problems with his king he has problems
against the pair of bishops but more than
that what can matter a lot is the
chamber with 5 minutes
kasparov with 47 seconds 59
I don't know but the knight returns
four and the knights installed here
where four ib3 control many
important squares the bishop of
seven for example would love to go
sometimes five would not love to go sometimes
five to the bishop to enter f1 with
serious attack but for the moment the
knight of four  he is holding it
rook of one in a practical way if they
had the same amount of time i
would say gary has quite an initiative
series authors of an
excellent option played
also a bishop  to four threatening
another record of 4 also bishop of 5
threatening the bishop of the knight
directly and also trying to
unblock the where of because always
where of that it gets to unblock
very risky for the couple in short it is
all it seems a bit surprising to me
that  change change the rooks I thought he
was going to keep the initiative he
may think he is going to keep the
initiative instead of staying here
king and king is the one who brings the king yes but
we have a passed pawn let's remember a
past in exchange for the  bishops
5 I imagine that reggae 3 and then a
g5 and he registers more seeding market
and a great past has an
extra pawn he has to be a little careful
dandruff 2 in this position than 5 of
course so that they don't make him efe 4 and  5
so that they don't f4 him quickly without
changing the board he will also say that he
wanted whoever has an extra plan in the
assumption that he will try to win
but he is still far from doing it
let's continue with this position  on the camera
against kasparov that 5 has just made the
best player
in many years 15 years he
remained the best here against the capture of the
world
efe 4 but see
4 plays here nakamura trying to create
passed pawns see that the knights are going
to block a  knight on 4 and a knight
on f3 blocking the opponent's pawns
and he will be playing very fast very precise he
has to have here it's two bishops
against two knights but I loved that
move on f4 ef 4
excellent move excellent move by
hikaru nakamura extra move one way
excellent and he has made the king from where he
is at the moment knight to meat
and dss and knight f5 eliminates one of the
bishops and now the matter is the
passed pawn of four is the pawn for each
day 4
unstoppable we are going to have to spend a lot
cash energy for 235 to stop this
pawn because if you stop them with the king this
king of 3 enters 4 enters 5 me
as a great advantage at
some point to control the
entries by the  king and on the
black squares both in four
and in which the pawns are falling and
enough to try not to fall in the where
of five because if it does not start to enter
if we already have a result,
fabiano caruana has won as it is not expected
against yes  david navara for the moment
good result
i think hikaru nakamura has a huge advantage
against garry kasparov i
think the advantage of the passed pawn on
a4 is huge that excellent f4 move we
have to remember that hikaru nakamura is
an excellent player who takes advantage of all the
resources  of a position and
garry knows he's in trouble
directly on camera
if we're going to see I'm waiting to
qualify or just play 4 act
start advancing that pawn because as soon as I
play 4
I don't have kings 5 because at 435 I play knigh
s of 6 I change the  knight for the
bishop and the passed pawns crown with
ease
very strong is
if here I can try 4 a pin of 8
to try to control the advance of the
top 5 I think what he has to do is
control control the position but at 4
it seems to me that it is quite a tough move it
is black who tries
to equalize the position that is quite
obvious but maybe he still has the
resources to do it still maybe  maybe he
has the resources to close them
who knows is the pressure is on
dandruff where in return he is not going to lose this
game this position never apart
from the time the time we have 2 minutes
37 against kaspar or 49 seconds
I will finish at 4 as we had
finally said  of 8 and knight of 6 that is trying to
capture jan efe 4
knight that is he who has to
move he moves it sometimes I don't see the great
dispersion it's wrong there is not much
difference between 5 and see if not we are not
clear that it is a  big difference because
kings 5 f 6 and i can't take on f 6 by knigh
by 5 if th
bishop was at 5 and shoots that
can't play record f 4 by ef 7 to 15
5 and pass the pawn to 5 to 6  to 7 until
he distracts the bishop and co  ronó the pawn
has calculated very well here picaro is
wrong dandruff 2 is wrong
now yes
yes definitely in the film and a5 much
better move and we will see what
is happening efe 6 try to keep
the pressure here knight by 5 king
but difficult defense here because
what happens if I'm going to capture the pawn and
that's what we have network four in six
knights of four and this pawn is going to be
captured without much difficulty
on each trip two are two pawns are two
pawns that I'm  threatening here I'm going to
threaten h4 and I'm going to pass the worst 14
and 1
in h I don't know if he has time dandruff 2
and go for the pawn but they are playing
extremely fast we are seeing it on
cameras extremely fast
see what he does see what he does in  the
camera we put them on camera that blocks
the bishop but I don't know if he has the time
because here the king returns
quickly the king
returns I think that if he returns on time we will see
time
in the position if he does 7 I have a bishop of
4 and there is no  no one position and I
think there is I think this one I think there will
be no danger because the knight
cannot get in the way because if the king does not enter
we will see if what I say is
true he still has tricks here in the
cameras let's say a g8 knight  he can
threaten this it is very important that
when he threatened a knight g8 knight f6 he
has the bishop in the right place in the right place
he
is still trying nakamura but they
are already tricks this is a final that must
be a draw there is no more for him for the
time being  I am a master, he does not have a minute and
so much 12 minutes 27 against 45 seconds and
remember that 10
seconds are returned to you, they are returned to you, they are not
accumulated, they are only returned up to a
maximum of 10 and I think he has managed to
save the position and what he already  careful
careful
let's go where we're going efe eight has
horses pe 6 you have to be very careful of
that trick 15 times I think there are still
kings 7 is enough but he's trying
is that they don't put a sub sol I
think 6 e  It's a little simpler
at the moment I don't see any trick
that could help him on camera I think
it's going to end in a draw, by the way,
the game between
Leinier Domínguez against Vision and another
final of Cuban
rooks has ended in a draw.  the beginnings here delineate
very solid two tables
he is known he is known as a
solid player who does not have many risks
in the meantime I was already putting h at the
moment he has a quality of less
against levon aronian but a
very unclear situation as soon as this
game ends we will go  for there yes we will go to make
a summary because we are still here and
yes well we still have to be careful
because there are its tricks but
you said it is an ending that is obviously a
draw and
not I think that both players at some
point let go of the midpoint I think
that  nakamura was winning at some point
but with such little time it is almost
impossible to figure out exactly
where the bishop has to retreat here fi  the
one to one and there is no way for the knight to get in the
way it is already a draw in all between
the jícaro nakamura and garry kasparov
I think it is a good result at a certain
moment it seemed to me at home but it was
better at a certain moment it seemed to me that it
was better let's pass  they arrived in the game
against the fmi h with seconds
nothing more seconds
aaron against nepomniachtchi item has
two pieces against a rook in this
endgame
rook of 3 efe four three of three
aronian only playing with the delay
with the ten seconds that the
law band  as you can see it does not matter if he makes a
lot of quick plays they are not going to hit him
with the asset he has no right in 13
minutes
13 seconds of little in 48 seconds yes
in this area that he is playing he is
completely won against e.coli in
that game  your rf3 will finish soon and
let's continue until we get here to
aronián ineco machine camera
aronián nepomniachtchi on camera if
we have here tower a1 aaron and lines
and we have them here on camera I got on  aa to
say that he is trying to win that he currently
has two pieces against
a rook he has those chances of
winning but pieces very active very active
that the important thing is those rooks on f3 very
clumsy on the f-file he is
going to try to put pressure on him here he
put me  his opponent and he always has to
be careful aronian and it's also not
easy because he has 13 seconds 13
seconds to defend himself
knight f 2 the knight enters see there is
aronian 5 seconds his dances but this one
up there has the problem that
there are ideas of mate something  like 15 5
bishops 7 to 15 5 bishops 7 seems like a
tremendous idea to me maybe we can have it
here in the analysis of five bishops 7
trying a knight and that's all
in a box of 265 as we said
preparing mate
for that axis 4 for  play a g5 and
save yourself from that but knight 4 of course
now again threatened ideas such
as rook h 2 followed by ef bishop 2
and then g5 check rook h 3 let's see
if they kill me where e  there is the mate there is no
mate yet rook than 2 threatening
bishop f2 the king extremely weak
extremely weak 8 6 7 6 5
up to a maximum of ten seconds less
but three threats kill a control axis
and well we have here
and they don't laugh at the rooks  of 32 82 they
laugh at then he wins I already got like that
with the black pieces a split move
against the organ incredible octopus
had instead 5 and has won I already put a chip on him well
we have another result more load
here he beats the and how well
and not  he beats aronian if he wins the
game too much to see how
it ended we already liked the
carjacking position from here
and what
happens here
and the ending
was simply not satisfactory here
for it suits him because he loses one of
the weaknesses  that we were
talking about this idea of playing knights for four
nights of 3w one and t
is endgame with a pawn down past the f
le is very difficult because there is becau
e the rook is already behind the pawn which
is exactly where  e want to be
at all
this ending is difficult but maybe it
can save you if I have to save stage
no but you say it seems to me a
very strange move because now with the tower
with the cut well I don't know if I go
the farthest away
you just go well
well we already have the results of
the second round today's second round
the white walk paros
aronián is a very, very
big game very busy here aronián epo
who win bet this part
really impressed key key and
good cardiac and beats y  how well
lenier domínguez draws and thinking about this
tournament very very solid two draws and david
navara loses against fabiano caruana
so we had already seen him he is quite
lost when I say the game to the
first game
javi should have won
yes definitely but well we are already
after  two rounds of the day tell us and
see what the scores are
let's remember that the Welsh in
rapid games are worth twice what
they are worth  n in the plis so a win is
two points tables is a point and a
loss nothing exactly that is very
important this tournament is worth double the
beats it would be a simple score the
camera is placed in the first position
with three points out of four well we have
also impacted each one with three
of four anep or with three of four him and
how well with two of four aronián 2 of
4 look at this loaded with 4cast unemployed
of 4 2010 2 of 4 they win with 1 of 4 and
well david navara started losing
these first two,
as you can see, we have a lot of two out of four
if the tournament has only ended,
no one has won the first two
games of well one is expected not
that a tournament so so so close
this is what happens and well nakamura
with three  out of four drop i found
is four in economy out of three out of four
has a very very very slight advantage
over most most have
all 50% yes well kasparov really
started very well very well these two
first rounds
nakamura wins the first round
then draws with kasparov who right now
is leading along with buying and kings
also who has three out of four
draws with kasparov and wins as well and the
inept also who did not do very well
in the ones he involved but he comes sent him
establish the first one with the yen and
beat aaron either glory that he had
won in the chinese economy endless cup is
like revenge and revenge beats
the rapids
a nice game where we were
expecting a great attack from
white but no  proposes a queen nf3 for
a knight in 5's nothing happens and
we can quickly review the game
because I liked it a lot it's a great
game we really leave it as it
is here it looks bad for efe 3 control
the kingside and see what happens from that
eventually nepomniachtchi is
forced to sacrifice an
exchange or lose the ds4 pawn but in exchange for the exchange he
has an excellent but an
excellent pawn and the octopus octopus 5
loses  aronian and his knight which is
so crucial to coordinate the pieces
because if in this white knight it
is not impossible to get rid of the 5-knight
and if the 5-knight with the 5-pack
the bishop of one cannot be activated
because I am not going  to be able to take 3 I can't
organize anything on the kingside and that
is basically dead strategically
queen g4 even in the endgame
nothing changes in the endgame aronian is still
lost yes because of the activity of
the black pieces we see the knight on t5
a Chilean  3 active where the pieces
of aronián are so touched each other
completely to the mind truncated each
other to the film 4 and eventually
aronián wins if a piece because we already see that it
is impossible to stand 2 on that 2 they
simply take a knight from 4 and this
ending is already  I went where we saw it where the
coordination of the black pieces
begins to give a mating network to his
opponent and he is finally lost in this one
if more with the time trouble
it is really difficult this  position but
I thank all of you again
thank you for following this transmission
we will still be in the third
round of this tournament this day if
you can not miss it because we will have some
spectacular rounds as soon as
we leave as soon as we see each other we will return
in 15 minutes  here to the studio attention
coffee go to the tacos and we'll be there
in 15 minutes
[Music]
[Music
] expulsion
[Music]
jackson we are water works on sondheim
experience
[Music]
and
[Music] well
[Applause]
no
[Music]
i
[Applause]
[Music]
e
or not
[Music]
here
[Applause]
[Music]
good
[Applause]
no
no no no
[Music  ]
now
[Music]
yy
[Applause]
to
[Music]
[Applause]
e
[Music]
no
e
[Music]
y
ah
[Music]
and
very good
[Music]
no no
and
[Music]
ah
[M  úsica]
[Music]
and
[Applause]
[Music]
no
ladies
[Music]
therapy
[Music
] sometimes
there were no countries no parks works
don't understand me humility
wow pérez mi  rating
javier promise is the plane
in botswana light health and leaving him very
collectors with down
méndez
ortega
[Music]
and
look
[Music]
yes
how are you here welcome to the
rapid tournament and blitz of san luís
we are already going to the third round in the
live broadcast from
the city of saint louis missouri here
with grandmaster alejandro ramírez and his
friend and see good excellent games
they have given us the first two rounds
where we have three leaders with three out of
four who are hikaru nakamura sergey
karjakin and  jaime poniachik and
we still have several important duels but
of course for all of latin america
for all spanish speakers we have
a luxury duel so we have the
great gary kasparov playing with the
pieces b  lancas here in the third and
last round of the day against cuban
lenier dominguez obviously we
can't miss this duel between
marrying lenier dominguez but well it's not the
only interesting game
we also have fabiano caruana with a
carjacking al and how well against whom
against nakamura
it was his turn, he has shown a tremendous level,
I think he had small problems in the
opening with freak stoppages where the
couple at the end seemed very strong
but he recovered and I even think that at a
certain point they might have been a
great final bet so he has shown
very  good level he beats him with some
ease with the black pieces in the
first round of the day and for the moment he
is still one of my players who
have the best chances of
winning the tournament of course and we also
have net against david navara
we also have anep or with  david navara
david navara who has not had a good
start with 0 points
ineco comes with everything because well he is
within the  the pointers with 3 out of 4 that
an anti-group beats him in a cross and
rather the lion aronian in an excellent
way he sacrifices the exchange
positionally wins a very nice game
oh with an excellent horse in 5 of ian
nepomniatchi over aaron already
recovering  and taking revenge beyond the
first round of the endless cup
yes a week and a half ago and well
finally we have nan aronián
with white so well to orion this
mind has two points out of four
let's remember that in the rapids they count
twice as much as him  bliss so he has two out of
four aronian after losing to
nepomniachtchi and they win for the moment
he draws with domínguez in the
second round he only has one point out
of four since he lost the first and
well we already have this third round the
third round of de  this day because
tomorrow we have three
more rounds if we are going to lose we
start in garry kasparov's game against him in
jr dominguez a calesa most
likely domingu  ez plays those
solid orthodox queen gambit systems
4 icon there we are horse
efe 6 well known
caspar o late was waiting for us
thinking between the sexual options that
are to be 5 or bishop and that 5 are
considered the main moves in the
position  you can also see each f 3
but it is not the most common there are houses for
deciding that what he wants to be
known for was for being 5
when he played this at the
professional circuit level but we will see at the
end 5 has a lot of theory
lately  returned well from 7
4 has different names from 30 to
69 it depends on what white plays and
where and how do you say where the
exchange queen gambit goes which is here with sports 5 is
something that has only recently been
seen again  and you are going to see how something playable had a
bad reputation it had a bad reputation for many years
sport 5 sport 5 for black
but lately they have found
certain resources that it has been very
difficult for white to try some  kind of
advantage so let's see kasparov her
thinking that what she wants to do maybe
someone who is not following chess
not as closely as the others well she
must have some idea but maybe she hadn't
spent so much time preparing it is from
this variation  specifically that
despite being very common not at the gm level it is not
seen as much as let's say a game Indian
an idea of a queen a Catalan that are much
ore played 3 is very normal efe 3
and 65 are the main
ariants of the position any
another thing I see a bit strange
and well what do you think that it does not have to go
with the compatriot anier he played the best
player in latin america let's see if
he can beat garry kasparov
here showing that he still has a good
level he starts with two draws with two other
players  extremely strong
sergey karjakin and ficar o nakamura one
of the best players who plays this
with my fat magnus carlsen if we call he
also likes it a lot it
was precisely the 27 co  n some
3 head 3 and some
there is a line that made it very fashionable
a 6 very fast if I have seen it
good a game a little slower here
from both gaspar and
domínguez and horse f3 is to get a
little more important than  3 which is also
possible
we will see what kind of lines they are going to use
many times others put the care
with h 6th row h4 bishop h4 hey main
that what kasparov plays
[Music]
many times is what you see but
well we start a little slow  here he
the game between gary kasparov and dominguez
we leave some of the other openings and
move on to fabiano's game against
sergey karjakin to a draw against sergey
karjakin for less he recovers in good
form in his second game after
leaving like this in the first round where
column with the nono usually when he
loses he hides and this was not the
exception when he lost with nothing in
addition and against the law with him and now he
is here it would contrast what someone would do
using an old line  from lalín his
india with b6 very fast b6 I have
not seen this variant of 65 and f4 for a long time I have seen this a
lot I mean I had seen it like in
the beginning of the year 2002 2003 but the
hand of rustán maybe the hand of his
coach rustán almost  plains that
I have a lot to have was exposed
many times the ideas of queen f3 damage
e3 and simply going for the
kingside in the most common thing black for his
part tries to get rid of this
knight of 5 to try maybe I
have to  go in 4 to cover this
film and maybe what would someone who also
has the time do not see this because she
spends a certain amount of time playing
knights at 6 and as I repeat I
have had some time not to see this
specific variant
today has  enough here to bite and here
we have that with fabi we don't have
well maybe not gentlemen with fa
let's say with the good fad and we are going to continue
in both for the openings le quang and
against hikaru nakamura
that has already passed enough  I will give you a line from
the Catalan and very well
a Catalan that despite the fact that we did not see
a single Catalan in the endless cup
we did see this idea of g5 and f5 in paris and in a link
rom the camera where
I kne
that he  f 4 was playable but
also bishop c3 is very playable
from 13 to 15 between state sport is more
playable
the end of f4 we had already seen this
many times we have already seen it in
tournaments where there are many times these
variants of f5 and g5 weaken the
black's position and on other
occasions they allow him some kind of
attack rooks c 8 it is done so that he
behaves 5 that is by 5 comes with tempo
I have to take care many times not to
allow this pawn of 5 to remove and
achieve  that he entered 6 precisely because of
this entrance of the queen,
well, we have there, it
is an acceptable position,
we can have my idea as with white
with a c5 to try to block the
bishop instead,
yes, of course, they did play four,
extremely common, black wants it  take
because abr  and the bishop here I can
prepare the 5 and very common this idea
plays 3 first lequan well but it would
not surprise me if at some point he
prepares 1465 made precisely against
the 7 bishop I think he first plays
3 so that this 4 loses some of  effect
yes but it is very possible that at some point we will see
the advance of the b pawn for
as you say precisely 4 or 6 5 years ago
well well already very happy and very
excited I have not had the opportunity
to go to the game room here we are
commenting but we are  commenting but
yes i am very excited because the
baku ogre is back he is here and has
started in a very very way
and they are very solid and gaspar with two out of
four
let's remember that he tied with carjacking he
tied with nakamura
a good start for gary kasparov
well speaking  of lanes let's see the
game let's go to the grip part
I think there is someone left between fourth and
sixth place I think there will be
I think that between the three of us we are going to
see the game of kasp  arov against lenier
domínguez that there have already been many changes and
to prevent precisely what we
had said about knight of 4 gary
starts with queens of 2 but this allows
the breaking of that 5 that what
domínguez does that they see that he has played
extremely fast where he leaves a
isolated pawn in his structure but in return he
finishes his development very quickly
this is the current position we have
where
kasparov can play against an isolated pawn here
the 5
's are usually considered a very very
very very slight advantage for white but
difficult yes but  very difficult to break
very difficult to break this type of
position he is also unaware of these
positions well if he is a player as
we said before he is extremely solid
and he will not have any problem
playing this this structure where he is
very slightly better but he tries to
maintain  the good position and we see in the
shell clock with 20 minutes
ledger with 24 minutes if we remember that it
is 25 minutes by 10 seconds
so Domínguez has barely spent
minutes while Kasparov has spent
more than five
reaching a position that, although I don't think
it is purely theoretical, the ideas are
quite normal since here this rook
enters 8 and protects the 5-
threat pawn in  at some point take the f 3 and
1 of 4
because it is not going to be the most
exciting game of the day but it is going to be
something that we are going to pay close
attention to because the carry we are going to see what
kind of pressure he can put on
domínguez  also and he tells him I'm going to
get solid
I'm a rock you're not going to be able to win icardi
is the one who's going to try to win
this position rather than win he was trying to
exploit this static disadvantage that
he has in jr
or if we're going to see  see if the ogre from
baku manages to win this game because
we know that ledger dominguez is a
very solid very
solid player that for example I have always seen
several turns that he plays and he always
stays with a draw if we go to the
game  me like this against david navara
david who starts here with a terrible
tournament losing the first and the first
round and then being against a
brilliant aaron and if he gets brilliant
and then he is annihilated by
fabiano caruana with the black pieces he starts
here he charges expensive kann against already  I put
here a very sharp charge of bishop f5
where we see that he quickly breaks a
stick and continues with an attack he continues with
bishop for b 1 queen for b 1 g4 and he throws himself on
top what he does is destabilize the
center with his f 6 we have bishop  for c 4
and has played and a strange position where
we see all this
development advantage that he has put h but at the
moment each one has its chances
of counterplay especially because it has
a large center that can change from
4 x to 17  breaks between 5 and 6 5
probably the threat here is
pretty awkward i would wait for the
horse play on boss 6 i
have to figure out what happens if i get caught
on that 6 if it doesnt work if i dont have
com  Thought
I don't like this position at all
if it's risky there are people who like to
play like this now he's never afraid
of this type of position it does
scare me a little more he's already played lady efe
6 he has to be very careful because
let's say one  played as knight f3 which
seems to me to be quite a tough threat here it is
5 first start with the end h 5 check
to force the queen somewhere the re
somewhere either 7 out of 8 and when it moves to
one of the two squares I will play
knight f3 which  champion of 5 attacks but
more important than attacking the clan of 5
the bishop can be played ah4 nailing the
queen against the king so fillet 5 and they
already put problems to the rod that
is also four minutes below his
Russian opponent on the clock
or  well he loses the first round he loses the
second round he is the player who
is currently in the last in the
last position where he loses the first
round against aronián he loses against
fabiano caruana and well let's see
fabiano is recovering  for at least in
his game it's not a bad game he
was there against lequan well totally
won he had done everything complicated and
when it was time to find a
precise move to defend himself he can't
find it and they end up mating
him they end up mating fabio cardona
tournament
we have done I think that in the chamber he
is a great favorite for the tournament
I think that in quick
I think nakamura but well he is a good one
I am not going to give all the places
one for me that the chamber is the favorite
now
but after the king  of 8
this inspiration already cut me off that there are not
many players here who have many
possibilities there are many players
we are also going to move to another position
which one we are going
to let's go to the one with levon quickly anal
against lemon which is something that
we always have to have enough  present two
incredibly strong players although he
doesn't have the best start no if they don't
win he starts losing the game
against the camera draws against him  yen
very solid aronián wins a
brilliant game against the stick in the
first round but green against
net the same way h shows an excellent
level when he wins that game and
we have an Italian
with a 4 to 5 a fast 5 and we are going to
these kind of well known structures
where aronian
maintains a great development a stable position
but after the current position of f-
knight 7 he has his couple of moves more
than 4 f 5 from the current position
white definitely has pressure
here on the flank of  queen taking on
b 7 and the kingside let's say trying
to do something with each neighbor and
when like that what you have to
calculate is the problems with efe 4
at the moment they are doing efe
four to anna which is a  double attack
on the knight's bishop but more than
that it's not so easy to get rid of
the pressure because
but I'm also
you like the end of 5000
I don't like much to prove that after they
are doing me  do f4 and in the philips it is
being locked up correct after
five I don't like the fact that it is finally
there because as soon as I remove the queen
I will have ef 4 and h 6 and it seems to me that the
bishop can be if I remove 11 8 and there is
enough left  misplaced so annan has
to find some way to save his
pieces but he is hardly in a
comfortable way to fix himself if he can
have pressure on pardon who sees
7 over plans 5 and over all the df no
co while black has no  at the
moment
some way to really create
direct threats more than what you have here in
efe when you know I like to have the
jail idea five queens out of eight but
with the idea of knights and four to avoid
access 6 in a way the recipe but the
knight stays there the knight
stays there attacking a bishop in gestation
is that it really can't move if
f4 already took four out of six then
I went too it would be instead it's a little more
dangerous that's how it starts to be  efe bishop
7 is never possible because I have
set the bishop is flying so I
like set 5 but with a knight h4 of
course when when I put the knight
on h4 I like the black position much less he
is right white fits very well
press f5  but now the things
that I was saying but more than that
knight
because 6 many times it will be very
uncomfortable precisely when they arrive they play the
bishop g5 and I think that he already has a
superior position against aaron already because of
this idea that he was giving me as a knight
ch4 it seems to me  very important I really like
this position for the next 5 it has
to be also concave elche 4 those two
quartzes are important at this moment
otherwise the position would be very, very close to the
side if you play 35 anand and then we go
to other games that for me
there are several games  very exciting
but I think that already so fast well we
will finally see h5 check king of 8 and I was
waiting for the f3 knight move that
still seems extremely strong to me because  ue
threatened knight by 5 and threats
ranks and 4 but maybe it sells for me here to
find as a little stronger
castling short
of 4 that maybe necessary but ef
if I like a very typical theme opening
the position opening it with a  f I think
he is going to have to make a 3 yes but
I will play 3 4 3 it is a bit sad because
eventually the pawn will be lost of
course and apart from that I have ef 4 and then I
give my knight dh4 a square for
placing it on the 5 it would be part of that
I have the bishop h4 very dangerous
so damages 6 will attack at last if he puts me
here he removes bishops 7 and give me a very
important one because the queen here is
defending the knight that was
trapped and at times I keep taking them
in 4 of course if he chooses 5
in what they play at bar I imagine that
pawn times four is the most logical move
I don't see any reason not to take if I
don't see any reason not to take n4
he is calculating you for example by the 4
knight efe 6 that double attacks an
intermediate like  the steak 3
everything is  e style of matters of what he
is calculating at the moment he did not put
insurance making sure that there are
no real problems of course
here I have for example bishop for it is six
things like that that he also has
to take care of the whole position is falling
and  Besides, I have the fn 1 column,
too, which is very strong, looking
at the king in black, it's terrible, it's 8,
it can't hide in 67 because I
have bellies, it's threatening, add
if I like it a lot, just take the
horse, it's the boss, I can imagine the  idea
but suspicious that I
can
do something here in this tournament because it
started badly it starts very badly and the problem
above all is that the rapid ones are worth
twice as much it is not difficult to recover from three
defeats the same thing happened in paris
defeats and although our tournaments and
especially the  leads is doing pretty badly
and it went very well for him it was not enough
to recover and let's hope that
navarra can at least finish the
fast one it's better because it's u  a very
very talented player who sometimes plays very
well sometimes plays very badly unfortunately today
he is not in his best form and
I don't like his position he
is very very suspicious already with a hostage of
8 yes what do you think if we go to the
position of anna brown and take a
look at him or we go with him with caspar or
not always with caspar or not to have
a vision that if we are going to see algae for
someone else we are going to see kasparov
after castling rooks rook 8 ago
has not changed essentially  the position
between kasparov and dominguez where after a
knight to 6 as we had talked about he
will try to put pressure here on
the pawn from 5 lenier he will simply
try to return a whole rock and
say that a weakness is not enough
to lose of course  that white
is slightly better that he doesn't
have any problems in the position and
that he rather has quite easy pressure
on 5-pawns I like it a
lot because he is already putting pressure
on  The session at this point is 5 and we see a
block that is difficult to make from 4 to 2
so that is like the ideal, not the
ideal is that he manages to play 4 and for the
moment I would say that he is trying to
calculate if 4 works or  it doesn't work
from 4
I don't like it from 4 there is no problem
from 4 right away and it did from 4
but nothing for 7s you have a risk
let's see what is happening if
knight 34 I have knight for 4 now
you can't take the  only because someone
has to defend the bishop I can't
take you as a pawn because you let me take
some in the fill n 2 and what are you telling me
that there is a pin it is only apparent
because it is pinned as a slave to me with
film 5 where the queen  attack the rook and
bishop attack the queen so tactically
if it doesn't work for kaspar os
if I take I take and he took the bishop I have
knight f3 check and no one is
defending the rook in fingers hit
an exchange so I can't take a box
if I take a pawn  first just
bishop for f3 and something for  the style
could be playable just to
capture before 4 or the most dangerous
knight f4 hitting the bishop the bishop
has to stay defending the
knight on f3
a position that I don't like so much
for kaspar and that's why he makes
your queen for  7 is that I like it because
well I don't have any for 3 because
I just eat the one that of course
I like I like this idea because I have
a bit more
good let's see if linier recovers it
here we put 3 394 quickly done by
the Cuban putting  here pressure on the
position of dandruff 21
rook of 11
of one
first of all around the euro I do not have a
rook of eight that does not catch anything we carry
prevention
if all of one I probably have to
play 13 1 to resume I have to
resume the attack on the rook  here
in de 2 I think this hard rook c
1 and 4 real de 1 I have to play
e1 tournaments to attack this rook again but
after all that I am not so sure
that it goes to fences for example if it takes
I remove macará I have threats on b2 and
I have a lot of activity that eventually
I am going to lose the pawn I must 7 I will not be
able to stay with it all my life for the
reason that yes yes
and I have almost everything that is doing there
14 and 14 so as not to lose that  where I
can't see his report 7 by rook of 7 or
ideas of rook of 7 I also have to
take care of 3 that advances the pawn and yes
it seems to me that it gives more than 4 it gives him
enough against the game even though
he has a plan  from less rook to than
one what kasparov plays
we are waiting for rook is one of
liniers c1 rooks of the emir that seems to me
that he still gives him enough counterplay
I think this is fine
and all of 2011 a good part of the accumulated
good game so far it seems to me  of
liniers that even though he is a pawn down, he currently
has a lot of
compensation, a lot of compensation, let's quickly go to
Fabiano Caruana's game,
which seems to me
like that position has loosened up a bit
and I don't like Kaya's position very much
ky we had not left it after
abc 6 transfers the knight axis 3 with
idea of knight h5 removing this defen
er from f 6 which allows me to play event
al bishop for h 7 an attack on this
ide bishops 7 b 3 which especially after
the row  3 because here they foresee
prevents caruana from entering the knight
because it is pinned but singer gigot and I
play rook 8 I have to take care of this
tactical blow he took as a check here
since here penal rooks
enter with mate so I can't play
rook 8 because it weakens efe 7  it means
that a bishop c8 that is quite ugly is
still eager today yes and queen f3
immediately asks caruana to his
opponent
is what he is going to play because well he
has right now that I can play I don't know
give me f3 it seems to me that here he attacks
because the five  I don't have a square for
the bishop on 8 no because bishops 6
I always perceive that it is f 5 and
bishop f 5 looks very curious agile because of ef
if you are taking on f8 you ca
n't play you can't play like that but what v  aa be
what is he going to do and that is what he did to the
film 7 very sad but that is what he did
he had no choice it is very sad what he
is doing nearby and here I like it
I like the march 3 that they have threats
not only night 7  that the obvious but
also knight coming in from 766 starts
starts to mess up the sm5 positions
and punishes as black has
really put together a clumsy series development
that would make an unusual for him but
fabiano here with the big big forward i
think queen h3 is  a very
successful move attacks here on the kingside
taking advantage of the fact that there is no way to
deduct series that queen h3 would do here
for example let's analyze if g6 efe 586
g4 we go why not 45
we open here
and since we are talking the knights of
7 threaten here the  knight of 6 am in
each rook on f8
well I have to take care of the circe 8 what
I was thinking the end I know 88 what a
nail
I have a nail here I have to have a
little shame
taking six volumes of 6.7 and of course lady
h5 that attacks the five-pawn and however
you define it well it also attacked the rook
in the ugly if it can't defend both it
simply loses some material and
that's why it was dangerous it
backtracks to the one I like just let's
see what happened  Some of Garín Hogar and
Lenier are playing as I thought Let's go
to Nepomniachtchi's I want to see the
game here for me because it has changed
a bit also that it has happened well
we were waiting for the move
we are waiting for the move
efe for four and a horse efe six  and
we weren't so sure but
definitely better for white
but it was a weird prophylaxis of rh 1
and after bishop 2 I'm seeing that
I was getting done he's looking to the
right he's looking to the left he
knows something bad happened to him the
position  because after bishop 2
over 1 bishop g5 he realizes
his knight
is being eaten and the knight is trapped so he doesn't
have to play one on one if he wants to
repeat nav  arra give me twelve what he plays
I imagine he is going to repeat with axis 5
to return to the city christine on 5 he
has to because otherwise he would be in a
lousy position but already in this
position I like it
[Music]
I can't for effect  it is defended
in 6 of 105 atoll of 5 with the
initiative that enters with the queen
and apart from that
I have one more
and that is good under 1 tower there is one
but he has done it in exchange for a piece
that would be a free attack now it is  a
piece if it is not the same here I have had
to sacrifice material that seems
unnecessary to me
well thank you very much for following this
transmission thank you for your comments
for your nice comments we send you
a hug and really
thank you very much for following us send us
your greetings send  the comments here
we are going to be very attentive let's continue
with kasparov's game that has
changed a little more so as not to be against
domínguez
we saw this idea of torres e1 torre for sure
e took for granted  he took two rooks from one
and now instead of playing a four
that he was giving me that seemed
dangerous to me because of three they take 17 kasparov they
take 2 and there is the current situation that
if he takes the 4 they simply take
4 it seems to me that with  the rook doesn't see a
problem I don't see any danger
but with the knight I think it
's fine too
and black's position I don't see why it
should be inferior to
white's position the bishop here against the knight
is not a big deal like that with  all the
worst in the same on the same flank e4
is extremely risky because a pawn
is a passed pawn and basically kills
3 it does not sound like I
agree that very solid dominguez
spending very little time see what
a big advantage
the cash clock has for with 6  minutes 40
against Domínguez more than 17 minutes
more than 17 minutes
in return
I have to prevent them from taking three I like to
give 95 for a rook for scenes that
take rooks for 8 and I am putting
everything there if maybe 5 yes for everything
for a tower  s for 8 knights for 8 and
I have a queen check and if the king moves
I have the bishop haq it
can be three more he
is behind just more equality I was
thinking so I can play queens for 8
maybe you don't know I'm not sure if
you can pass the worst because it demands that
there is no perfect here and you can not play
the 2 because team check you think
but instead we are going to have a very
possible draw queen b1 what
kasparov chooses I think it will end in a
draw after queen by b  1.91
just take on 3
I don't see any problem it has already
stayed there we are taking b 1
we can also see them
and already up close on camera 343 the bishop is
simply not superior to the knight
very solid very solid kasparov and
dominions also no  the 2010 in with three
boards today that maybe not what
one expected but they are three boards
of each one but well a good
a good start I think it is a good
result for the Cuban master for what
reason because he is very  solid its
co  I start and it's black although it wasn't
good enough to make three draws as
you say the color influences work for
efe 36 these draws draws are making
sure that they can make draws before
30 that the rule doesn't exist because since
they don't have a spreadsheet they aren't totally
sure
in the 29th
the referee chris verg will give permission and draw then
between gary kasparov and lenier dominguez
we will have leinier dominguez in the
studio with us
analyzing the games because
no we won't have we have 33 players who
speak spanish david navara lenier dominguez
and the great visionan  in hip
hop we had him here in the studio and they
were all in that option we hope and
we also have kasparov now he is
maybe but well I already put him here and
now he plays against david navara and
ends up in a draw he decides not to risk
and go for that  sacrifice of piece that
they were telling me instead of going on
tablets after a blog of really
with re h1 where we thought that david ib
aa to lose but the imf hy for some
reason play one and not reinforcement in a
perfect but decides that he does not want to
risk with a less
good piece but this position was not what we
expected definitely a good
start for the putter it is already the last
game  of today if perhaps he didn't
want to force because well he gets
a good result with the snow he
beats aronian and draws tables
then I don't think it's a bad
result it's solid very solid not at
all it's not a bad result for  nothing
because we already have the results that he
protected against linier domínguez tables
nep or tables against david navara so
we go with the game of le quang liem
against hikaru nakamura which against
a cannula we go down here and we have an
idea
efe 4
and both players fight here  because of the
g file km controlled by black
but I can always play on axis 1 it does not
appear that black has a
serious problem here even though he has a
bishop between 7 m  very bad in the field
effect 3 it is not
really better the wild effect 3 does not have
any superiority over it in the end it
must 7 it is very possible that
all the pieces in column g
will be changed and this will end more or less commented
it seems to me that  it's going to be a draw
we're equal in pawns it's
difficult for both players to enter
and again they change if everything changes
at any end of the film it's going to be a
draw but there's no way to enter with
the kings
most likely they'll end up that way
we're going to correct  some try here expensive to
make some kind of complication try
to find one of four somehow
complicate the game but I think that
after 54 of course that 5 without seeing
leaves me nailed and many times I don't want to
take with the pawn because I have left
I've had the worst here so it's 15 5 I don't know
exactly how the jícaro is going to try to
progress
and I don't know what the result is a draw and aside from
time we went 10 minutes and 35
seconds white and with liam with  after eight
minutes normally there is not one time
for a player and no I don't see a problem here
for either of us we go
then
to the game which game we are going to
then which one we would go to because
here there is not much
fabiano against doing and yale  we leave it
after the move the film seven
witnesses well at the end of three a little
slower than what we had said about
a machete pear bin it is very fast to
five here it deals with some kind of desperate activity I
wanted kingdom h3 now yes
in america in  instead of f5 he plays as a knight
of 7 double attack he also attacks here the
bishop at 7 and well he has
if he wants he simply eats the rook
someone what he has done he eats the rook
fineffe 8 is one more quality for
fabiano it is a lot of material
this position is  an image quality
of 6
675 to continue with the attack that
I also like this idea of continuing with
orward it tries to remove the knigh
that can defend in some posit
on I am
dge 6 and take advantage of t  also that it was
the end is that 7 in b 7 if I tried
to try to be a tom for example with a
gate to see why I can start playing
all the president check took here I
return the quality but see how it turned out
from the kingdom of f1 nobody since  that he doesn't
even have to take in bills and
that all of it represents a great and
great threat if he wouldn't have time to
take on b3 I really like this idea of
the 6 and playing efe five I think it's the
most accurate way and more  technique to
win this position yes thank you very much to
everyone who is watching us they are
waving from mexico from mexico
greetings there
and well
we are very happy and very excited
to be here on the first day of the
rapids and clicks of san luís and well
we are  in the rapids and later it
will be the gleeks that are 18 rounds
rounds 9 Thursday 9 on Friday from August 14 to
19 they are not asking if
we are going to save to transmit the
ultimate books I think not in Spanish
I think they count them  ba later it's like
an exhibition there the james clock is very
fun that we're going to have on Saturday
but obviously it doesn't count as
just
and well while Peruvian decides how she's going
to win this game I really like your
idea of bishop by 6 and  play an f5 and
now we go forward
with nothing
where the position
between vision and levon aronian
f5 has changed a lot we liked the position a lot although I
warned 5 intermediate see how interesting
the position becomes there we have
talked about that we did not  liked queen 08
for knight h4 of course and here bishop for
eight knight for b three bishop for c 7
trying to win a pawn but this
exchange sacrifice because she takes and takes and now she keeps one less exchange in return this knight is
locked rook  c2 that because of that a
unique head 213 and still has
nowhere to go that's why the rook tactic begins
with 817 rooks c8 and does not want a
draw this position does not want a draw
here
at all but they take e  l 5 with a
knight surprised me a bit because I thought
that I could have a bishop for 5 they had
we have every time for 5 knight for that
amount for the 5 and a nice f4 see how
nice avoiding here in the idea
because what threatens on that five
sectors  on 5 direct
I have efe four he tied the pin n 5
well I liked to know
the players on cameras because we have a
guest here a very special guest
yes of course as we see here on camera
aronian at the moment has a piece
also receives quite strong on 5
but I don't think it compensated, they are two pawns, they
are two pawns, what the meeting has
in this position with a disadvantage of
material and a disadvantage of
time also 4 minutes 45 against
almost 11 minutes of aronian it seems
difficult for the Indian grandmaster to survive
but he is a very tenacious player
there are still two quite strong
and passed pawns and the material is somewhat
reduced the 2b 4 knight and well
we are here in the studio with the best
player  r from latin america in jr domínguez
welcome to san luís and welcome to the
tournament
well we gave a bit of your day it was a
tournament a very solid day and you end up with
a great player how that game felt
a long awaited moment not for me he
played against barrel
the position is good and i think with the
sequence i did it's pretty accurate
i'm not sure but i think it's 4
just like here waiting for this
precise 4 they take here if you trade on f3 and this
queen entry i didn't think maybe
rook  1 but it is also a bit
risky for
some, everything changes, we enter this ending and
nothing happens very evenly but perhaps a
rook of one that puts it at risk for
both but of course
with little time
although the general white is quite
out of danger I would say  In this
position, because of what I was having here, I
thought I would take between three
times, I think I should take with a coma of a
queen of Trent, they change the unit somewhat,
but it seems very flat, so we have
to  specify let's say that I want
to win everything worse if I take the
pawn then I think they exchange one and
also eater
of 7 external portage
maybe like in b 2 directly instead
of exchanging so that here I have nothing
else because 7 has
to see something different  against d3m
maybe something like more active a rook x
than 1
2 like that try to have an
active rook
good in the end solid net results
draw 2 with black
satisfactory results im pretty good and
especially the first day a bit difficult
always
let's point language
a little bit the nerves but now
it seems to me a pretty good result to
the game I struggled a lot and I hope
I hope you can help here
a little analysis since we have here
and well he has taken out the day d to play
two we have  caravan against
carjacking that we still liked
very much caruana's position has
turned his positional advantage
seems to me a material advantage and that's why
cháve  z there the instinct to finish off to
stop the stage let's say that
bishop played there from 66 because 6 we already saw it
surprise and we have the family not against it
would be carjacking queen and 6 check where
the king goes
and this here took bishop for details
bishops  5 between the rook
we must also take greenish here
I have more with the file five bishops
tuning of territory and there will be
clearer than 83 here bishop f4 and some
mate there must be reforms in three
also on Tuesday yes very well this is
mate that's how it goes  plus six I can't play
rh8 but I don't know what he's going to do
so 17 I can't do the same
maybe here he took tome the
same it seems that black's king is dying
we have 17 what's here
yes
h 7
still the move  rook f 8 sounds like a
lot to me at least he has removed bishops
5 check but he has not got rid
of rook ideas he feels without eating the same
maybe if I have to have
I will take six fingers and they are all the same the
same one we have seen it has to go the same
up dh 6 I don't see what they change
because if minimum minimum is not very
sure and well here we go it already
took on f8
queen by ef 8 bishop by 6 and what we
are waiting for is that it
basically surrenders to tomatoes is first sorry they
take from  6 first taking advantage of the fact that
no one is defending f 7 I think I also
program also because the rook comes in
here with efe 7 well of course yes
technique to take from range checkers
like the only html5 checker
where it is simple you don't have to get too complicated in
the end to say  he must win
let's go to the other game not in those who
give two games he is here from jícaro
trying to win they still control well
we already hope that he will win family
carbon defense be victory qing wang
here against hikaru nakamura onda maché
6 white is the  which has a
black
out man and out of the woods I always have an f 6
if the queen runs away from 8's to try
to create a counter play down the
c file whenever I have to
worry  queen f 6 and well I know
he has given up rather in this variation
that we were watching the game closely
and karjakin exactly as we are
seeing it until g3 and in unstoppable mate with
queen h 4 and he recovers in a very good
way
fabiano caruana  against close to
carjacking
and le quang liem it seems to us that he is
pressing a little bit with a little bit it
must be a draw and the only
game we have left is against
levon aronián who appears to you in this
ending obviously better for aronián with
one more piece but  still won
everything defended from the knight will come back from the
game of play and try to start
threatening the auction
while I can't throughout the region there is
a very strong coordination on the part of
black and white just has one
I think just count our
preparation for this tournament as  surely
someone is preparing for a
rapid and blitz tournament that is not the usual well
always
that is the usual preparation the repertoire
such but a little  more emphasis on more
practical things solving problems playing
practicing these rhythms a little also
for me the delay was a bit
unfamiliar and I tried to practice a little
before the tournament like I did
as we saw many times in paris that was
the first the first tone of the great  chef
turn we are using delay that there are some
values that were not accom
odated much
ore the i
crease of that
s why we are trying and well defin
tely thank
you very much for coming here for joini
g us in the studio we go here in the p
ayers' chambers where well we al
eady have a couple of results that  I think
that evo has not beaten vigilance
and we have the game ego has
beaten vision and aronian recovers quite well
from super defeat against ian
nepomniatchi and well we still have a
game to finish the day
thank you very much to the grandmaster here
venier  Domínguez for joining us and
hopefully we will see him there the top 3 of the tournament
thanks we see the last game that we have
left l  e quang liem against hikaru
nakamura on camera
wherever building a little interest
in the game we see let's see that one of his
pawns not the pawn of 3 and the pawn of 5
are strong the question will be which one is
stronger than the other magic  he has
very little time left, very very little time, he has about
a minute 4 left with
someone 5 minutes 43 has complicated the
position because now the pawn of 3 a
certain dangerous
where I am
javier granda is worked
payack and accompanied by
[Music]
from the  calm down but away from me it
's a pleasure to be here with all of you
well we have pending the result of
liquefying well against nakamura well what do
you think my twin where they move away well
I don't know where such
things came from well here the great teacher
well
ok then we have  pending each
game of the ico in honey where it is seen that he
has a clear advantage and well
[Laughter]
well the great master Alejandro
Ramírez here is going to explain the
position
well we have here with blanc  ace the
vietnamese grandmaster against the
american grandmaster nakamura well we see
this position where white clearly has
an overwhelming advantage
what do you think
you don't turn around think what do you think what do you
think
well yes screen
62 which is quite exciting here the
I play because well it threatens to win in one
here l with someone with a mate but
let's hope because queen is 5 what we have
to calculate gives us more than 578 that what
is going to be the canon 5d camera is
overwhelming in this position I don't see
how  the one that zidane
trying to
in this endgame of the king at least now
for n 6 and I think yes
today they arrive the same wait experts wait
it's not very bad
after attacking I finished 6 I didn't like it
maybe you have thought of me f8 check win
take f8 give me  lazy that wins dan and ivette
2009 nothing nothing because it is more than 8 da
for g8 and and this ending is not
financed it is won this plan is very
weak n 3 today the reason is your own evil
10 remove my voice how am I going to
avoid  your voice
well
after san luis
j where did they get this
give yourself
an impressive player the success
of the usa team also an incredible person
who obviously has
too much time on his hands again i
think we should already take care that he
does something there is no job we have to
make it
good
and I don't like it so much because it separates the
pawns which means that now
after two the exchange of queens does not
win because all the endings the king is going
to be close enough to the
pawn to annihilate what
could really be exchanged the pawn  of two because
as a pawn of 6 I don't see that there is a problem
here for jícaro in the endgame I think
that is as it says part d
with 40 and I worked a lot I worked a lot
the advantage I had I had a great
advantage and in time
yes
if they give f8 as you had  said queen efe
eight g8 queen for and is that it is the pawn the
worst is the problem of five and nothing else
is that eventually
and it is no longer the end of 4 rf12 and he already
captured the worst and it's over  baba but i think
i think he made a big mistake
a big mistake lee kwang jong
give me five queens seven king f2
and i think this endgame just isn't
better for white
well well well folks don't stop sending
regards from chihuahua so so so so
chihuahua this song is very good which one
brings so so so so
chihuahua greetings to josefina mínguez
greetings to all of you thanks for
following this transmission
and it had me today what an
impressive day we had today of everything we saw
all the emotions that you cannot
feel extra joy  sadness I'm not anymore
[Laughs]
no but as a cat imagine that fabiano
would have won his first against which
every round as he recovers he
recovers in an impressive way
annihilates the stick and then he shatters the approach
since he shatters it and does not finish it off  with
a kill it rules 5 it kills the axis 5 I do
n't really kill it I kill it completely I don't completely remove
the board well I don't remove it
well after we get to  this
position here is a little trick, not
that if they take six this endgame then
obviously it is lost because white
will have time also that is not very
difficult no
yes very typical so he can but if he
cannot take in 63
I am not sure why at  end of three
that what they play h6 to this endgame in
everything that is going to enter this endgame is
two pawns down and carl which
means that I will never be able to take n
6 but how to win it is not easy
it is not easy  maybe we can see them
on camera since they start
faster I think this smells like well that he
must win in some way but I
don't see how maybe it's a draw maybe it's
even a theoretical draw because it's
difficult to penetrate with the king he has to
have  very careful jícaro that
the king does not enter and if the king manages to attack h6
the game is over it has to have
some form I think it leads him to
try to put axis 3 there goes reggae 3
put the king in h4 in h 5
Mexicans always goes  to try that
this bishop stays on some diagonal
that prevents the entrance of the king
of moves to see are instead states
in houses
bishop h5 and by goes to the end only the idea is
that if bishop efe 7 bishop of 1 again
so that it does not enter  the king of and I don't
see where he's going to go in maybe he'll go
to the other side of he's going to go
around him a few times he's going to make him dizzy why not
why not try to make the opponent dizzy here
but I'm not I'm not seeing
how specifically  it improves the position
yes because it will never allow the
entry if the king will be that it is going to
change diagonals if you are going to
continue changing diagonals
also to 44
that what you are doing there is no king of 5
enters enters 4 of course
it is not so easy because if there were four
and he returns the backhand 5 he threatens both
lines 6 and 16 at the end of three
strong units 5
and he also does not have in check because I
tablet and he can be instructed
let's say to the film it could be that after
five  be suction there goes five
because  now that he plays
but king enters and enters maybe not
directly or maybe he is a little more
patient 7
maybe he is a little more patient maybe he will
play when he finally 43 if not you
will never enter he has to be careful yes of course
but that is how they both deliver  pawns places
it is given to both pawns it is not so
simple it is what is going to deal with them and
active 6 wants to try to win
if they want to tempt them to win until that was
the only way but I have a time that
is the problem I have a time with a king
of four and  well he is also
calculating it may be that in the end he wins and
he does so he hands over the bishop let's see if he
manages to stop nakamura the pawns
I'm not sure how they will do it it starts
with let's start with 5 to give to
sing the king to cut the king
important to play  rise 5 frye 4 the king
has to weaken go the other way
I hope he starts with a 4 because the
general rule is that you want the
plans to be in castles I don't think he would
have I don't think he would have time if
he had  cho that would have been a player of 3
I don't know I'm not sure how to assess the
endgame I think it's a draw I think he
can't force the pawns I think the king
returns on time but let's see let's see how
difficult it is to play this endgame with seconds on
the clock it
really is seconds  in which the
citizens we have at home play
quickly
because they have to attack the good ones from
behind I think that file 2 cannot leave
but I did it 6 roots it is very important
if you are letting the king enter at 7 and
the worst ones became caravia  but now
I think that I still think that he's going to
lose or expensive he's going to preach he knows he
can't for beige tones 7 is
unstoppable if king of 8b 7 gives up
annoying annoying hikaru nakamura
and turned to him
and expensive typical naughty annoying with  the
result
and of course it is that he loses against the
reading or mario at the end yes in the
end nice sacrifice he makes at the
end of the game
wow what an ending bbb how he got annoying very
annoying states  and we did not
send them a kitchen camera
wow
that is to say that you really have to wait
and thank you very much to all of you for
following this transmission we had a
spectacular day as you said where
we had sadness we had joy
we had everything true that everything is
everything we had yes good friends  of all
we had here you I think we have lost
our minds
the towel
is better it
is really good to
remind all of you that
tomorrow we will have another three rounds of
this fast tournament that you cannot
miss tomorrow see you at the
same time  one pm here saint louis
missouri time where you have to be
aware that the baku ogre is
larmier domínguez david navara lee kuan
well we have some great players and
well what a show what a show and a
good record
let's see again this final that we had
between far from mexican  nakamura what
do I think he forgot if expensive this
difficult law from many years ago reminds me of
the difficult game I don't remember  rdo against
whom I think it was petrosián where in
the tables they make law be put from behind
not from the front because the king does not arrive
but also the king goes from behind here
to 4 and chases the worst one chases the pawn
and chases the pawn and so on  it is a draw
because after the accident I stay
here I stay less for the pawns
completely for the pawns than to
advance times because it is unstoppable so
it was rather the king from behind who
had to play they arrived instead of the king I
knew that stable
was an idea of  a fission game
that had been seen before but fisher
astana commented on a book about this
about this ending that wins him that he does not
remember the petro but so badly they
bequeath one of them to us
in an ending that was drawn in the bay
should have been played by  from behind
well tell us level we already have three rounds
three rounds have passed today
as we are in the score well
behind and reminding them that it is a
double score where the game
won is two points p  tied game
is one point and lost is zero points and
how well tied for first they
are and also with four of six
aronian four of six caruana four of
69.4 of six b we have four tied
for first place then there is nakamura
with 316 carjacking three  out of six kasparov
three out of six lenier domínguez three out of
six and well they speak volumes that they did not
have a good day with one of six and
a difference a little bit
bigger between they win wash in the others
but only one point separates the one who
is  in the first place and here is the
eighth if tomorrow we have the
fourth
the fourth round
we will have navarra card already here
nice of her I think a bullet is going to
give her a little impetus not to lose that
game she had today against
nepomniachtchi in  the last round
I achieved I thought that if I lost the stick again it
would be psychologically difficult to
return tomorrow but at least
finish in a draw that gives
him those airs and I stand up  ce that maybe he will
have opportunities tomorrow he goes with
white it would be the one who has just lost
annihilated against by caravan so I
think it will not be an easy duel for the
Russian I think Navarre has his
chances
we also have the camera caruana
nakamura caruana typical american
duel typical duel  where they always play to
break their heads and it will not be the
exception they
have their pique of course because sister arrives here
takes away the
American championship from nakamura who has
not yet recovered it
there is pique I go with me I am going to fabi in
that game
dominguez
when I meet because  well he hasn't
lost one but he hasn't won one either
a solid start here from
dominguez yes very nice when it's not like
that I think two nothing more very very nice
very nice
great person there really is that
you can talk to him about anything
if he is very knowledgeable very  cultured
perfect English like that really
if I like that which is talking about
other topics sometimes talking about the same thing of
course  yes then they will do and ancash
stoppages nor is it game
aronian caspa
the last game we have against
good friends here
then he greeted everyone to bolivia
colombia argentina chile anime
and me with some mystics dear to costa
rica and well one pm one pm don't
forget we'll be here  a pn
is my being and he sent me a huge kiss to
all thanks for joining us
remember tomorrow three rounds are three
bigger rounds rounds that we are definitely going to have
tremendous and
we already had them today and I think tomorrow is going to be
even better it is going to be  even better excellent
how they start here and
we'll see you tomorrow see you tomorrow a big kiss thanks
for following the tradition a pm hour of
blood
well
good
for me
[Music]
but